when we left off in the last video
things were not going particularly well
for the english settlers at jamestown
they had managed to survive a couple of
years by the skin of their teeth but by
1610 they had endured such incredible
starvation
that they were actually leaving
and as they were just leaving the
chesapeake bay they met a ship with
english reinforcements who ordered them
back to jamestown
and came bearing orders from england
about a new strategy in jamestown
and these new orders were carried by a
new commander
here this was lord
delaware
spelled a little bit different but the
the state of delaware today is named
after this gentleman
and lord delaware said well it's been
great that you've all been trying to get
along with these powhatans
uh but let's get rid of them
so he switched the english from their
small amount of conflict with the native
americans over stealing food to a pretty
much all-out war of extinction
against
the powhatans
and delaware was
a veteran of the irish campaigns to
subdue that colony
so he brings his
tactics of complete brutality and
submission of the native population to
the new world he raids native american
villages
he burns their crops
and generally promotes an idea that
there will be no such thing as peaceful
coexistence
between english settlers and native
americans
that the only
thing for native americans to do is go
away or die and these conflicts between
the english colonists and the native
americans living in this virginia
tidewater are called the anglo-powhatan
wars
the first anglo-powhatan war ended in
1614 with a brief period of peace
when this fellow here john rolfe
married
pocahontas
it's kind of a
peace offering
but
by the time that the second
anglo-powhatan war was over in 1625
pretty much the entire
powhatan tribe had either been killed or
driven from the area and therefore this
english war of extinction
against native americans had succeeded
now john rolfe made another contribution
to the colony at jamestown beyond his
marriage with pocahontas he also
discovered that tobacco
was a perfect crop
for the kind of
marshy virginia soil
and tobacco was a commodity that was
getting hotter and hotter in europe and
so they discovered that they could grow
pretty much as much tobacco as they
possibly could and
markets in europe would just buy it and
buy it and buy it and so although the
colonists at jamestown didn't find the
gold that they were hoping for they
found a very different way to get rich
and that was through cultivating tobacco
and this is going to have enormous
consequences for the development of
virginia as a colony both in terms of
its geographic
development and also the development of
its labor force as tobacco is an
incredibly labor-intensive crop these
english planters in virginia will
quickly look for ways to staff a labor
force in the new world and one way that
they will do this is through the
importation of african slaves the very
first slave ship arrived in jamestown in
we'll talk more about that in the next
video